[موسيقى]
مساء الخير مشاهدي العربيه واهلا بكم الى
التاسعه مع العيال اختيار استهلوها بابرز
العناوين
دبابات الغرب وتحذيرات غربيه لاوكرانيا من
التقليل من اهميه بخمه استراتيجيه
[موسيقى]
تظاهرات واسعه امام البرلمان الاوروبي
تطالب بالتشدد مع ايران وادراج الحرس
الثوري على لائحه الارهاب
طالبه دقيقه
[موسيقى]
وبهار طبيبات فقدنا العمل تحتيان الماسات
عاما من التخفي زعيم مافيا صقليه وخزان
اسرارها في قبضه الشرطه وايطاليا تصف
اعتقاله بالنصر الكبير
[موسيقى]
مشاهدينا قبل ان نبدا التاسعه سانتقل الى
هذا المباشر وهذه الصور التي وردت قبل
قليل عن تظاهر ووقفه احتجاجيه مع النساء
الايرانيات وحيث تم عرضها على برج ايفال
في باريس واذا بمناسبه احياء ذكرى مرور
اربعه اشهر على مقتل الشاب الايرانيه مهسا
اميني على ايدي قوات الامن كما تشاهد هنا
فام في ليبيرتي الان تم عرض على برج ايفل
في فريق في باريس وهي ما تعني طبعا امراه
حياه حريه ووسام ووسم موقف الاعدام في
ايران هذا وذكر بلديه باريس مشاهدينا في
بيان ان الخطوه تاتي تحيه لاولئك الذين
يقاتلون بشاشه من اجل الحريه بينما يستمر
النظام الايراني في اعدام المحتاجين
فلنسمع لما يقوله المتظاهرين
عصير
مراه حياه حريه هذا ما يردده المتظاهرين
في هذه الوقفه
التضامنيه والاحتجاجيه من امام برج ايفل
في باريس مشاهدينا طبعا الى هذا الملف في
سياق التاسعه
[تصفيق]
اذا بالعوده الى بدايه التاسعه غضب روسي
من شحنات الاسلحه الغربيه الى اوكرانيا
دفع السيد الكريم الى التهديد بحرق
الدبابات الغربيه كيف بانتاج خط مدمر
بالمراهنه على التصعيد تهديد لم يلقى اذان
ساقيه عند الغرب اذا اعلنت بولندا انها
تنتظر موافقه المانيا لتزويد اكياس
بدبابات الالمانيه الصنع والمتطوره ومن
المتوقع ان يشهد الاسبوع المقبل جهودا
دبلوماسيه مكثفه لتامين اسلحه اضافيه لكيف
مع التركيز على احجام المانيا حتى الان عن
امدادها بالدبابات او السماح لحلفائها
بارسالها اليها
دي فيفي
مقدمه لحرب عالميه ثالثه لذلك لا يوجد سبب
لمنع الدعم لكييف او المماطله فيه
وبالتالي ادعو الحكومه الالمانيه الى
اتخاذ اجراءات حسمه بشان الاسلحه التي
سيتم تسليمها الى اوكرانيا المعركه من اجل
حريه ومستقبلنا بلغت درتها ونحن نتحدث
الان واذا كنا نستثمر لسنوات في معدات
الحرب الثقيله والدبابات فيجب ان تترك
لتصدا في المخازن بل يجب وضعها في ايدي
المدافعين عن اوروبا
لافتراست ايستور هاوس مشاهدينا للحديث
اكثر عن التطورات الميدانيه سينضم الينا
بالسجون الان عبد الجواد الرشد مراسل
العربيه في روسيا اهلا بك عبد الجواد امم
بدايه تطورات الحرب لماذا يخاف الغرب
بالنقطه التي وصلت اليها الحرب ماذا يعني
معركه التي تدار الان على تخومه
بالفعل المعركه اليوم اصبحت في تطور
متسارع بشكل كبير مع التصعيد العسكري
الاستخبارات المعلومات التي تقوم به موسكو
خلال اوله الاخيره ضربات عسكريه ثقيله كما
يتم تقيمها
القازفات الصواريخ من البحر من منصات
الاطلاق يعني معركه سوليدار كما دار
الحديث في الاونه الاخيره رغم الاستعانه
بقوه فاجنر التي لها باء طويل في الاعمال
القتاليه الخاصه الا ان الوضع هناك حتى
هذه اللحظه كما تحدث الروس هو تحت لكن ما
يخيف موسكو هو القلق الكبير من الضغط
للسلاح الغربي حقيقي
هو معروف في حال سيطره القوات الروسيه على
مدينه سوليدار هناك خوف غربي من الاكمال
والاطباق على المنطقه حتى البحر ام
الاسلحه التي تقدم اليوم لاوكرانيا هل
ممكن ان تنتج تغيير استراتيجي على الارض
حتى هذه اللحظه كما تتحدث موسكو وكما
يتحدث خبراء العسكريين بان الاسلحه
المقدمه كيف سيتم تدميرها وتعطيلها كما
نرى اليوم الكرملين يقول بان الدبابات
الغربيه ستصبح رامات على ما يبدو ان
الحديث يدور عن صواريخ من تراث كنجال على
سبيل المثال لكن تطور وتقدم المعركه من
الصعب ان تكرههم حتى اكثر المتفائلين لدى
موسكو لا يمكنه الحديث ان المرحله القادمه
ستقدم على احكام القبض على باطنه
اي انجاز وامداد يعني اليوم نتحدث عن عن
اسلحه نوعيه كان الغرب يمتنع عن امداد
اكياس بها هل ممكن ان تؤدي الى انزلاق
الحرب الى مرحله لم نعهدها من قبل وهل
يمكن ان تؤدي الى دفع موسكو لاستخدام
اسلحه لم نعدهم من قبل هي مرحله لاطاله
عمر الحرب كما ترونوسكم يعني السلاح
الغربي يقوم باطاله عمر الحرب لكن كما نرى
بان موسكو اصبح حتى تستخدم
هي مرحله تجريبيه تدخلها مسك اليوم في
تجريب هذا الروبوت يقوم باصطياد الطائرات
المسيره وهو يعمل بشكل الالي لا يحتاج
يعني او شكل الاهلي والتلقائي يقوم
باصطياد الطائرات من دون طياره على مسافه
تصل الى 15 كلم وهي مسافه ليست بالقصيره
لذلك طبعا دخول الروبوتات على الموضوع قد
يوقف الطائرات المسيره التي تطال الاراضي
الروسيه وخط الحدود بين الدولتين
واحده نتبع الكثير من التقارير الغربيه عن
الخلاف الموجود بين قياده فاجنر التي تحقق
نتائج ملموسه على الارض وبين القياده
المركزيه العسكريه وزاره الدفاع الروسيه
الى اي مدى الخلاف اليوم يعني فيه نوع من
الانشقاق على الارض وما الذي ادى الى الى
هذا الانشقاق
رسميا موسكو تتحدث عن انه لا يوجد خلاف
بين فاجنر ووزاره الدفاع لكن كما نلاحظ من
معركه سوليدار بان موسكو تقدم على هذه
الخطوات باستخدام عناصر لكن هذا لا يلغي
عناصر قديره وقوات الشيشان وقوات موسكو
وقوات دنيه كل هذا مدعوم بالطائره ويعني
المسيرات السمائيه لموسكو بالاضافه الى
الصواريخ التي تطلقها موسكو ونلاحظ بان
الجميع يحمل تحت منصه وزاره الدفاع او
المظلاتها لذلك طبعا هذا الخلاف قد يكون
موجود تم نقل العمليه العسكريه اكثر من
مره تم الحديث مرات عده عن انتقاد لهذه
العمليه من قبل القاديرف او غيره عبد
الجواد باختصار بين فاكتور وقوات قديروف
من الذي يسيطر على الارض ولديه نتيجه يعني
عسكريه وتكتيكيه اهم بما انك يعني تعمل مع
طرفين اعلم ان المعلومات دقيقه ولكن
بتوصيل سريعه طبعا
يتمتعون بخاصيه كبيره في خوض المعارك
بطريقه احترافيه اما مقاتل الشيشان
فيعرفون جيدا طريقه همم يعني الحرب حرب
الشوارع لهم باع طويل فيها طبعا للمنطقه
التي يعيشون بها طبعا للحروب التي عصرتها
جبال القوقاز خلال سنوات الطويله لكن على
الارض معركه ماريو بيل تذكر الجميع بقوات
قديره وتذكر الجميع شكرا لك عبد الجواد
الرشد على وجودك معنا يعطيك الف عافيه على
كل ما تقوم به هي بتاعه وعلى الارض خصوصا
بهذه الظروف المناخيه الصعبه هناك درجه
الحراره تصل يعني
بالنقل المباشر الى 35 درجه تحت السفر
كل التحيه لك
قال رئيس الاداره العسكريه التابعه
لاوكرانيا في منطقه خرسون الجنوبيه ان عده
مباني تعرضت لهجوم مكثف مضيفا ان قصرا
روسيا عنيفا اسفر عن اصابه سبعه اشخاص
احدهم في حاله حرجه وفقا الاداره العسكريه
الاوكرانيه فقط تم- وتعرض مبنى الصليب
الاحمر ومركز اعاده تاهيل الاطفال ذوي
القدرات الخاصه الى اضرار بالغه طالت
البنيه التحتيه بخير
[موسيقى]
اعلانات اول رؤوس حربيه نوويه لتزود بها
تربيه
اول ذخائر تستخدم في غواصه
النوويه وان الاستلام سيتم قريبا وكان
رئيس روسي
عام 2018
على العمل باقصى الاعماق
وباضعاف سرعه اي غواصه او صواريخ اخرى كما
ابدا تفاخره بقدره الصاروخ العاليه على
المناوره زاعما عدم استطاعات تدمير هذا
الصاروخ عمليا والتصدي لهم
مقابل التسلح الروسي مشاهدينا وصلت معدات
عسكريه امريكيه الى الدنمارك بهدف اجراء
تدريبات عسكريه على الجناح الشرقي لحلف
شمال الاطلس 2007
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
اسهاب في دعم العسكريه المقدم لاوكرانيا
بدا يهدد مخزون الولايات المتحده من
الذخائر بالنفاذ وفق مركز دراسات
استراتيجيه الدوليه
ارسلت اكثر من مليون قذيفه من عيار 155
ملم بما فيها قذائف دقيقه التوجيه خلال
عام تقريبا تستغرق القاعده الصناعيه حوالي
خمس سنوات لتجديدها خطوط حمراء اخرى
قطعتها الولايات المتحده مع تقديم خمسه
الاف ومئتين صاروخ اسكاليبر الموجهه بدقه
المفارقه انها ترسل حوالي 1000 صاروخ
شهريا رغم ان انتاجها الثانويه يبلغ صاروخ
سنويا استبدال مخزونات هذا نوع من الذخيره
يتطلب سبع سنوات وادعوا مماثل بالنسبه
لصواريخ المضاده للد
واستنجر المضاده للطائرات ارسل منها
مشاهدينا تباع
8,500 صاروخ
و1600 صاروخ صنع هذه صنع هذه القطع يحتاج
بين ست وثمان سنوات هذه السنوات المطلوبه
لتجديد مخزون همم الاسلحه الامريكيه تطلق
جرس انذار على جهتين اولا حاجه الجيش
الامريكي الى الذخيره للتدريبات وكذلك في
حاله اندلاع اي حال ثانيا امكانيه اضطرار
اوكرانيا لتقنين القذائف واطلاق النار على
الاهداف ذات الاولويه القصوى فقط او
استخدام ذخيره اخف واقصر مدى واقل فتك
فاكرانيا مشاهدينا تطلق نحو
143,000 قذيفه في الشهر اي ما يقارب من
اربعه الاف قذيفه يوميا تقليله هذا العدد
شرط غير مقبول بالطبع بالنسبه للاوكرانيين
يستوجب تدخل جيوش اخرى
ولمرحله ما كمصادر لقذائف المدفعيه مع
ترجيحات بان تملا كوريا الجنوبيه هذا
الفراغ
[موسيقى]
بخموت اصبحت في الاسابيع الاخيره مشبعه
برمزيه سياسيه للجانبين الاوكراني
والروسيه وفقا صحيفه واشنطن بوست واوضحت
ان السيطره بالنسبه لروسيا تعني الترويج
لنصر هي بامس الحاجه اليه لاسيه مع ان
قواتها فشلت بالاستيلاء على مدينه رئيسيه
منذ الصيف الماضي اما بالنسبه للاوكرانيين
بخبطوا تشكلوا حصنا وايقونه للمقاومه
الخارقه بعد ما زار هذه المسكي اواخر
العام الماضي وجعلها ركيزه خطابه امام
الكونجرس الامريكي كما ان نجاح هذا الهجوم
المضاد سيظهر استمرار الزخم في ساحه
المعركه وبالتالي لاحتفاظ بالدعم المحلي
والدوري غير انه الصحيفه الامريكيه حذلت
من استنزاف حصار بخمه القوات الاوكرانيه
واسلحتها وذخيرتها ما يشل طبعا قدرتها على
شان هجوم مضاد منتظر على جبهه اخرى وابدت
القلق من ان تعرقل تكلفه القتال عشان
البخمط الاستراتيجيه اوكرانيا الشامله
لهذا الشتاء او الربيع المقبل هذا وحذر
خبراء من اي انسحاب تدريجي من باخموت او
سوريدار المجاوره او ترك الجبهتين بحجه
المواقع غير الاستراتيجيه نظرا لاهميه هذه
المناطق الاقتصاديه
[موسيقى]
الانتقادات والمتبادله بين وزاره الدفاع
الروسيه تعود لفتره لكن معركه سوليدار
الدجاجتها بعد اعلان انتصارات منفصله
بتوقيتات مختلفه روسي على ما يبدو استدركت
سريعا خطا قد يغذي النزاع المتصاعد وصححته
باشاده نادره بشجاعه عناصر فاجنر في
المعركه كما نفى الكرام لان وجود اي
خلافاتنر بل اكثرها ضمن اشاعات ومحاولات
تلاعب بالمعلومات يجريها طبعا الخصوم
وزعم ان النساء لا يتعدى المجال الاعلامي
وان كلا طرفين اي الجيش الروسي وفا بنك
اكد معرفه الشعب الروسي بهويه ابطاله الا
ان اشاهدت رئيس ببطولات قواته منفصله لا
تزال متوسط لا حيث شدد على استقلال قوات
فاجنر وخضوعها للانضباط الشرس وتمرسها
بالقتال واضاف ان عناصره يحققون كل
الاهداف بصوره مستقله لامتلاكههم الطائرات
والمدفعيه والمدرعات كما لفت الى اهميه
نظام القياده الذي تم تطويره بشكل تام وفق
تعبيره في انتقاد مبطن طبعا للقياده
العسكريه العليا الروسيه المتهمه بقله
التنسيق
[موسيقى]
مشاهدينا التاسعه مستمره فيها بعد قليل
في مقابله مع العربيه رئيس وزراء باكستان
يضع ثلاثه شروط للسلام مع الهند
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد خلال كلمه القاها بنت
عينيه رئيسا للجيش بحضور رئيس الوزراء
بنيامين نتنياهو اكد رئيس اركان الجيش
الاسرائيلي ان الجيش سيتم تشكيله من جميع
طبقات المجتمع على ان يكون جاهزا للحرب في
المناطق القريبه او البعيدده
مباشر الجيش الاسرائيلي للحرب في الساحات
القريبه او البعيده
وسنوسع نطاق التجنيد الجيد للجيش
الاسرائيلي من جميع طبقات السكان التي تعد
مصدر قوتنا كما سنعزز قوات الاحتياط
وسنحتفظ بجيش اسرائيل واحد هدف مبدئي بعيد
عن اي اعتبار لا يتعلق بالدفاع
[موسيقى]
في الباحه
ايرانيون من مدن اوروبيه مختلفه يجمعهم
مطلب واحد في هدف المتظاهرين الاولي
مطالبه المجتمع الدولي بوضع على حاله
ثوريه على قائمه الارهاب ونددين طبعا
بنتهاكات النظام الايراني والاعدامات
المتواصله شخصيات شهيره عده للنظام
الايراني عبرت عن دعمها للتجمع
ايران السابق رضا بهلوي وعلي كريمي وغيره
هذه ضحايا الطائره الاوكرانيه ايضا
المتظاهرات والمظاهرات التي جرت والتي
تحمل نفس المطلب المتكرر منذ ثلاث سنوات
هذا مؤكد سياسيون بينهم عضو بالبرلمان
البريطاني ضروره اقرار الحارس السوري
منظمه ارهابيه وقطع العلاقات الديبلوماسيه
البريطانيه مع ايران على خلفيه طبعا اعدام
المواطن البريطانيه علي رضا اكبر وكا
متاسفارتان الالمانيه والفرنسيه في ايران
نشرتها صورا جديده لسفيرهما مع السفير
البريطاني فيما وصف انه تضامن اوروبي في
قضيه اغتيال اكبر غير ان هذه الصور طالتها
انتقادات من الناشطين دعوا هذه الدول لسحب
السفراء وقطع العلاقات وليست تصوير فقط
ضخمه بالتحديد هنا امام مقر البرلمان
الاوروبي وذلك للمطالبه بادراج الحرس
الثوري الايراني على لائحه المنظمات
الارهابيه للاتحاد الاوروبي ويشارك في هذا
التحرك متظاهرون من حوالي 50 مدينه
اوروبيه توقيت هذه التظاهره ايضا يتزامى
مع اجتماعا للبرلمان الاوروبي للبحث في
سبل فرد عقوبات جديده على ايران بعد
الاعدامات الاخيره وسيحضره ايضا المفوض
السياسه الخارجيه للاتحاد الاوروبي
المتظاهرون اطلقوا هتافات مؤيده
للاحتجاجات في ايران
ضد الجمهوريه الاسلاميه في ايران وكذلك
حملوا رسائل مواجهه الى البرلمانيين
الاوروبيين كتب عليها كونوا صوتنا وماذا
تنتظرون بعد لاضافه الحارس الثوري
الايراني على لائحه المنظمات الارهابيه
هذه التظاهره لن تكون الاخيره لكن
المتظاهرين هنا يعولون على
والضغط الذي تشكله على القاده الاوروبيين
لمنع نصب المزيد من المشانق في ايران فادي
دهوك العربيه ستراسبورغ
ستردام ايوب سعيد الباحث في شان الايراني
استاذ ايوب هل ممكن ان يذهب الاتحاد
الاوروبي نحو خطوه وضع الحرس الثوري
الايراني على قائمه الارهاب مع ما يعنيه
ذلك من تبيعات بشقين سياسيه وقانونيه طبعا
تضيق الخناق على الحرس
ااا بدايه مساء الخير عليك ولجميع
مشاهدينا العربيه شكرا على الصداقه اعتقد
ان هو هذا الخيار يعني الاكثر مطروح خصوصا
انه
بالنسبه لطبعا ااا عدد عدد
الاعدامات التي حصلت مؤخرا بالنسبه
للطبيعه التعامل النظام الايراني مع
المظاهرات الانتهاكات همم المرجع همم على
مستوى الحقوق الانسان
يتزامن ذلك همم
باحتجاجات كبيره ومظاهرات مؤيده كبيره في
اغلى مدن همم
المدرب الاوربيه
همم لكن
المشروعيه ادراج المشروعيه السياسيه
لادراج الدوري ليس فقط لاعتبارات حقوق
الانسان وانما همم ياخذ زخما اكبر نتيجه
خروج الحرس الثوري الايراني من حدود
الاقليميه التاريخيه كانت دور الحرس
الثوري الايراني
مقتصر الى حد كبير على الشرق الاوسط في
دعم مدهشات وقلق بديشات وزعزعه الاستقرار
ولكن مؤخرا ااه راينا شاهدنا تورط الحرس
الثوري في دعم المجهود الحرب الروسيه ما
يشكل تهديدا حقيقيا
لا اوروبا
خروج الاتحاد الاوروبي من حدود
الدوري بعد دوريا هذا ما يعطي شرعيه حقيقي
حقيقي
استاذ ايوب يعني بالتظاهرات الداخليه كنا
نقول انه تمرد الهامش الاجتماعي على مركز
القرار وعلى يعني النظام على الايديولوجيا
همم التي انتجها النظام اليوم تمرد الهامش
الاجتماعي الخارجي على مركز القرار
والايديولوجيا ماذا يعني
حقيقه بهذه المباراه
التي سبقت همم
يعني سواء الحاليه كان الموضوع ادراج مطلب
ادراج الحرس الثوري او تجديد العقوبات على
ايران الى حد كبير تابوه يعني حتى قليل من
المعارضه السياسيه الايرانيه كانت تجربه
على طرح مثل هذه المقالب نتيجه انه هذا
النظام الايراني استطاع على العقود طويله
في تاسيس مشروعيه سياسيه حتى داخل داخل
الدول الغربيه تحديدا داخل ميديا الغربيه
نتيجه سيطره همم اليسار السياسي على على
الحياه السياسيه الثقافيه في الغرب ف- اا
استطاع
استطاع النظام الايراني بمنع
وبتحويل مطلب ادراج
الحرس الثوري على رائحه الارهاب او تشديد
العقوبات على انها تابع السياسيه ما هو
جديد في هذه في هذه الاحتجاجات هو ان تحول
هذا المطلب ليس مطلبا يعني المطلب حزب
سياسي معارض معين اول شيء هذا مطلب شعبي
داخلي طيور الجنه همم من خلال مظاهرات
وايضا ال- ال-
العشرات الالاف من الايرانيين المقيمين في
الخارج همم ايضا اذا دخلناه بعين الاعتبار
التاييد الدولي
الشعبي على المستوى الشعبي والنقطه
والسياسي غير همم هذه المظاهرات همم يعني
انتفاضه داخليه مدعومه بانتفاضه خارجيه
وموقف دوله قوي الى جانب الشعب الايراني
شكرا لك يا استاذ ايوب سعيد البحث
قال وزير الخارجيه البريطانيه ان النظام
الايراني قام بتعذيب علي اكبر بعد ما شرح
له الاخير ما تعرض له قبل وفاته مشيرا الى
ان اكبر كان ضحيه الانتقام السياسي
قبل موته والتعليم
وزير الخارجيه البريطانيه اكمل حديثه
قائلا ايضا ان بريطانيا ان بريطانيا تقف
الى جانب الشعب الايراني الذي يطالب
بحقوقه وحريته السياسيه
والاجتماعيه امام سياسه القمع الوحشي الذي
يتخذه النظام الملك
بعد عقود من القمع الوحشي من قبل نظام
قاسم بريطانيا تقف الى جانب الشعب
الايراني شجاع الذي يطالب بحقوقه وحريته
هذه الشجاعه تظهر من خلال الواقع المؤلم
بان اكثر من 500 شخص قتل وثمانيه عشر الف
اخرين اعتقلوا خلال الموجه الاخيره من
الاحتجاجات
لويس
[موسيقى]
الصور من لندن الاحتجاجات نقابيات تقام
امام ستريت مقر الحكومه البريطانيه طبعا
مع اعلان المعلمين الايرانيين اضرابا عاما
يبدا غدا وطبعا مع استمرار او المعلمين
البريطانيين يبدا غدا ومع استمرار
الاحتجاجات في عده قطاعات
[موسيقى]
في مقابله خاصه مع العربيه اكد رئيس
الوزراء الباكستاني شهباز شريف ان بلاده
تعيش وتريد العيش بسلام مع الهند بشرط يحل
المشكلات الاساسيه وقال الشهبات شريفه
باكستان والهند خاضتا ثلاث حروب وكانت
النتيجه المزيد من البطاله والفقر
لقد تعلمت باكستان الدرس
حروب مع الهند وعواقب تلك الحروب
حل مشكله الاساسيه هذه المساله مهمه جدا
يا اختي لذلك فان رساله الى القياده
الهنديه ورئيس الوزراء مودي
لنجلس والله خذ محادثات جده وصادقه لحل
مسائلنا الملحه مثل كشمير التي تشهد
انتهاكات صارخه لحقوق الانسان في كل يوم
وقال ايضا رئيس الوزراء الباكستاني شهباز
شريف للعربي ان المصاعب الاقتصاديه في
بلاده قضاءلت بسبب دعم دول الخليج واوضح
حارس وزراء باكستان انه يتم العمل على
تطوير التعاون فيما شاليه التجاره
والاستثمارات مع دول الخليج
جدا من الدول الشقيقه
من المملكه العربيه السعوديه او الامارات
العربيه المتحده والاخرى
عن الحصول على الايباد والهدايا من
اشقائنا الموفقين والمعتمدين هؤلاء كلا
كلا هذه ليست رؤيتي ولا ارى الامور بهذا
الشكل وامه لديها اندفاع قوي والقدره على
الصمود والشجاعه
[موسيقى]
اذا مشاهدينا كان هذا الجزء من مقابله كنت
قبل اجريت سابقا مع رئيس الوزراء
الباكستاني شهباز شريف للاطلاع على
المقابله كامله طبعا عبر موقع العربيه الى
ملف اخر وتحديدا الى افغانستان عارضات
ازياء بلاستيكيه برؤوس مغطات باكياس سوداء
او ملونه مشهد غريب ومخيف في الوقت نفسه
سيطر على واجهات محلات الازياء في كابول
ففي خانه قمع حريات النساء ارادت حركه
طالبان ازالت هذه العارضات من نوافذ
المتاجر او قطع راس العارضه تماما اجراء
احدهما اسوا من الاخر بعض بائعي الملابس
امتسالوا للتعليمات لكنها اخرين رفضوا ذلك
متضرعين بحد من امكانيه عرض الملابس بشكل
صحيح او اتلاف عارضات الازياء التي تعتبر
باهظه الثمن بعد هذه الشكاوى طالبان عدلت
القرار سمحت قبل ما تاجر بتغطيه رؤوس
العارضات بالازياء للموازنه بين طاعه
الحركه ومحاوله جذب العملاء اي عارضات
ملثمات وفقا صحيفه الشرق الاوسط فبدل
منقطع رؤوس العارضات في واجهات المحل
التجاريه لفوها باكياس
سوداء قماشيه او من البلاستيك بعض التجار
تحايلوا على الاجراء بتغطيه رؤوس عارضات
الازياء باكياس مصممه من نفس ماده
الفساتين الاساسيه حركه مشابهه لكمامات
صممت من خامات الالبسه والتي انتجت خلال
جائعات كورونا
[موسيقى]
في افغانستان خلف قرار طالبان الاخير بمنع
النساء من العمل في المنظمات المحليه
والدوليه مشاكل وصعوبات كبيره للمراه
الافغانيه العربيه
بعد ما فقدنا مصدر الرزق الوحيد
كانت طبيبه في احدى المنظمات الدوليه وقد
تعطلت عن العمل جراء الفرمان الجديد
لطالبان بمنع السيدات من العمل في
المنظمات الدوليه والمحليه تقول ان راتبها
كان المصدر الوحيد لعائلتها واطفالها
السته
التزمت المنزله بعد ما اعلن الطالبان انها
لا تسمح لنا بالعمل زوج عاطل عن العمل
وضعنا الاقتصادي ضعيف نعيش حياه صعبه في
منزل باجره
بهار هي الاخرى كانت عامله في المجال
الصحي في احدى المنظمات وقد تعطلت عن
العمل ايضا وابوها قد توفي منذ زمن وهي
المعينه الوحيده لعائلتها التي تعيش في
وضع اقتصادي صعب كما تقول
والمنظمات بدورها قامت بتسريح فيها
وبالتالي لم استطع الاستمرار في العمل
يقول عدد من الطبيبات والعاملات في مجال
الصحه ان القيود المختلفه التي فرضتها
طالبان على النساء الافغانيات قد اضرت بهن
كثيرا بحسب الطبيبات والعاملات في مجال
الصحه فان القراره بمنع السيدات من العمل
في المنظمات قد خلق مخاطر قاتله لملايين
النساء والاطفال الذين يحتاجون الى عمل
الطبيبات
العربيه كابول
تنضم الينا منك بولا فرح ناس سخ ازداده
الناشطه المدنيه
استاذه يعني اليوم بدانا نلمس النتيجه
العمليه لقرارات طالبان العشوائيه
الطبيعيه بحق النساء هناك اليوم ايضا
افغانستان على شفاء انهيار اجتماعي وهناك
ازمه اقتصاديه خانقه كيف يمكن ان يمتنعكس
هذه القرارات في الداخل على النساء وعلى
الاسر
همم سليمان جيدا
على ما يبدو اننا فقدنا الاتصال بفرح ناس
سخزادا ولكن طبعا لتذكير بان طالبان
بالفتره الاخيره تدرجت بقرارات القمر عادت
الينا
ليس للمراه حق العمل وحتى
اختي الرسائل
ان ترفع صوتها ومطالبها
فرح ناس يعني نحن امام مجموعه
راديكاليه ذات الجيولوجيه يعني متطرفه هذا
صح التعبير من المتوقع ان يتم التدرج
بالقرارات ضد النساء بهذه الطريقه ولكن ما
الذي يمكن فعله اليوم او من الجهه القادره
على فرمله هذه القرارات المشرفه
بل هي مشكله كبيره في مجتمعنا
فرح نازله يعني
الصوره
تتقطع بسبب صعوبه الاتصالات مع افغانستان
وطبعا الامطار الغزيره هناك هذه المنطقه
التي عانت من سيول
كثيفه وايضا طبعا كل المنطقه المحيطه امم
في حال عادت الينا فرحنا سنعود وناخذ رايك
عن يعني البطاله التي طالت النساء في
افغانستان وكل التابعات الاجتماعيه نتيجه
قرارات طالبان التاسعه مستمره مشاهدينا
ولكن بعد قليل وقتها
في بريطانيا انتقادات لحزب العمال بعد
اقتراحه بان يعالج الناس انفسهم بلا طبيب
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد مقترحات ساذجه كلينيكيا
وخطيره في الوقت نفسه جزء من الانتقادات
وجهات لخطه زعيم حزب العمال البريطاني
المرجو منها حل ازمه الخدمات الصحيه حيث
حذر خبراء الصحه من اخطر احد المقترحات
والمتمثل بالسماح للمرضى لاحاله انفسهم
للعلاج دون العوده فزعيم حزب العمال
العمال اقترح عدم الحاجه لمساعده متخصصه
في حال الام الظهر او وجود نزيف او غيرها
بل الرجوع الى الذات اطباء ان بريطانيون
ابدو قلقهم من تحول التشخيص الطبيب الذاتي
على الانترنت او ما يعرف دكتور جوجل
لمشكله اكبر في بريطانيا كما اكدوا انه
انا للتشخيص الخاطئ تاثير معاكس قد يزيد
طوابير المنتظرين امام المستشفيات للحصول
على الرعايه متخصصه صحيه في الاطار نفسه
مشاهدينا استطلاع راي بدات هو صحيفه ذا
تايمز منذ عام اكد انهيار ثقه الجمهور في
الخدمات الصحيه فاثنان من كل ثلاثه
بريطانيين يعتقدون ان الخدمات المقدمه من
هيئه الصحه البريطانيه سيئه للغايه
[موسيقى]
اعلنت قوات الدرك في ايطاليا اعتقال
الهارب رقم واحد في ايطاليا الملقب بزعيم
زعماء المافيا وذلك بعد 30 عاما من الفرار
حيث تم القبض عليه وهو يخضع لعلاج في
عياده خاصه بجزيره صقليه تحت اسم مستعار
زعيم المافيا هذا يعرف بانه خزان اسرار
المافيا فهل سيكشف خلال التحقيق معه خبايا
كثيره ام انه سيلتزم الصمت
وحده خاصه من قوات الدرك الايطالي
الكرفينياري القات القبض على هذا الستيني
نحيل البنيان في مدينه باليرمو بجزيره
صقليه ناقل المافيا الاشهار
الملقب بالديابوليك او الشيطاني اختبا من
العداله منذ 30 عاما بعد ارتكابه سلسله من
الجرائم التي اوصلته لتصدر لائحه اكثر
المطلوبين للعداله الايطاليه وضمن اكثر
عشره مجرمين خطوره في العالم
انتقلت شخصيا لجزيره صقليه لتشكر مسؤولي
القضاء والشرطه على هذا الانجاز الذي
وصفته بانتصار للدوله
نسينا دينارو ابتدا مسيرته الاجراميه في
مطلع الثمانينيات من القرن الماضي كاتل
ماجور بسيط الى عام
1993 حيث شارك في التخطيط وتنفيذ سلسله من
التفجيرات التي استهدفت قضاه وسياسيين
ايطاليين وعودت بحياه العشرات
وكان الهدف منها هو ارهاب الحكومه
الايطاليه لتطلق سراحه زعيم المافيا ان
ذاك سلفا تورينا وعددا من معاونه فشلت
حمله التفجيرات في ارغام الحكومه
الايطاليه على اطلاق سراح رجال المافيا
المسجونين فاختفى مسينا دينارو
لثلاثه عقود الى ان القي عليه القبض في
مستشفى في صقليه
مشاهدينا قبل ان نكمل بالملف الايطالي
ساشير الى هذا العاجل الذي ورد الان
الرئيس التونسي يصدر امرا بدعوه الناخبين
للجوله الثانيه من الانتخابات التشريعيه
اذا كان هذا اخر العواجل من تونس بالعوده
الى الملف الايطالي اكدت رئيسه وزراء
ايطاليا جورجيا ميلوني اهميه القبض على
زعيم المافيا ووصفته باليوم التاريخيه
مؤكده ان ما وصفتها بالحرب مع المافيا لم
تنتهي
همم
لكن هذه المعركه كانت معركه رئيسيه للفوز
بها وهي ضربه قويه للجريمه المنظمه واريد
ايضا ان اضيف ان اليوم هو يوم الاحتفال
بالنسبه لي
اوكي
رفعت النجار مراسل العربيه رفعت يعني
عندما نتحدث عن 20 عام من عمليه العزل
لالقاء القبض على من يعني فصلناه زعيم
المافيا عن من نتحدث وما اهميه القاء
القبض عليه
زعماء المافيا الهاربيه
[موسيقى]
اللذين تم القبض عليهما الواحد بعد الاخر
ورينا كان زعيم الزعماء وقد مات همم بقي
ثالثهم ثالث هما وهو همم نسينا دينار الذي
كان اختارهم واكثرهم دمويه
وكان يدير عمليات المافيا الدمويه وهو في
منفها الاختياري وهو مختلف
وتروا عنه همم جرائم كثيره جدا همم
يسيب لها
الولدان زي ما بيقولوا او يصيبوا لها شعر
الرؤوس
منها مثلا قوله هو كان يقول عن نفسه انا
مستعد لملئ مقبره بالكامل
بالضحايا همم الذين يسقطون من من خلال
اعمال الدمويه همم
والقبض عليه همم يعني خطوه مهمه جدا في
تحجيم همم اعصابه همم
المافيا الضخمه الاساسيه اللي هي قذره
التي تستقر في همم صقليه او سيليا والتي
لها جذور امتدت الى الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه
وراينا بعض بعض
نشاطها في فيلم العراب لمار للام براندو
هكذا وهذه همم استرا هي اخطر العصابات لكن
ال- ال- حكومات الايطاليه همم نجحت في
تحجيمها
هذه الخطوه القبض على هذا الزعيم ستزيده
سيطره الحكومه الايطاليه على عصابه كوزان
استرا امام عصابات المافيا الاخرى اللي هي
عند همم جيتا همم في همم كابريو وكامره في
نابولي
الانتصار كبير للحكومه له اثار كبيره
الايجابيه همم ضد المافيا التي فعلا كما
ذكرت رئيسه الوزراء لن تنتهي لانها موجوده
في كل ايطاليا
رفعت القبض اليوم على هذا
ثالث يعني اكبر زعيم للمافيا واخر اكبر
زعيم للمافيا الايطاليه هل ممكن ان يؤدي
الى تفكيك ما تبقى من المافيات هناك عبر
اذا ما تم ماذا اعترافات منه خصوصا ان
يعني تشكل عصب الاقتصاد الايطالي
بطبيعه الحال هو سيعترف ما فيش حاجه اسمه
حاجه اسمها يعني لن يعني هو سيعترف كما
اعترف همم زعيم الزعماء على عليه وعلى
غيره وبالتالي سيساعد هذا الحكومه في
القائل القبض على المزيد من العصابات او
على الرؤوس لكن المافيا لن تنتهي فعلا
لماذا لانه الان يسيطر على
الاقتصاد وجميع الاعمال ايطاليا ما يسمى
بالمصيا الراقيه او ال- المصيه التي ترتدي
همم
البدله والجرافطات الى اخره وهذه تشارك في
العطاءات الحكوميه بالملايين وهمم الانباء
ذكرت اليوم ان عصابات اندرا
اندرانديتا في كلاريا كسبت في عام واحد 60
مليار دولار
وهي تعمل اعمالها في كابوريا اكثر مناطق
ايطاليا واوروبا فقط وهي تسيطر على معظم
الصادرات المخدرات الى اوروبا يعني مافيات
ايطاليا اذا رفعت نحن نتحدث عن حرب مستمره
ومفتوحه بين الحكومه الايطاليه وبين
المافيات التي هي منذ زمن وليست شكرا لك
مراسل العربيه رفعت النجار عبر سكايب على
هذه الرساله
مشاهدينا الى دافوس حيث سينعقد منتدى تحت
عنوان التعاون في عالم منقسم وسط مجموعه
من العوامل التي تفرض تفرض نفسها على
اجنده هذا العام وعلى راسها التضخم وشبح
الركود وبتاكيد اقتراب الحرب في اوكرانيا
من نهايه عامها الاول ابرز ملامح دافوس في
هذا الشتاء واهم ما يميز هذه الاجتماعات
في هذا التقرير لمفته العربيه لارحبا
المنتدى الاقتصادي العالمي في مدينه دافوس
السويسريه يعود هذه السنه في نسخته
الشتويه لاول مره منذ الجائحه العام
الماضي اقيم في شهر مايو ما الذي يميز
دافوس هذا العام انا لارى حبيب لحصلت
الضوء على خمسه امور اساسيه اولا عنوان
المنتدى التعاون في عالم منقسم كوبريشن
ماذا يعني ذلك يعني ان العالم منقسم بسبب
الازمات الصحيه والاقتصاديه والسياسيه
التي لحقت به مثل حرب اوكرانيا
المعيشه والتباطؤ الاقتصادي كلها ازمات
مترابطه وحلها يستدعي التعاون بين
القطعتين العام والخاص ثانيا الحضور
الحضور اقوى من الاجتماع
غيره ثالثا المنتدى الذي سيطرت عليه الحرب
الروسيه الاوكرانيه في اجتماعات مايو حارس
هذا العام ان يعطي ايضا اهميه لتداعيات
هذه الحرب رئيس الاوكراني زيلانسكي يشارك
عبر الفيديو وزوجته حضوريا اما المليارات
الروس فغائبين للسنه الثانيه على التوالي
رابعا الحضور الصيني جيد وعلى راسهم نائب
رئيس الحكومه ولكن اجراءات الحج الصحيه
التي كانت موضوعه وترقب راس السنه الصينيه
في الثاني والعشرين من شهر يناير حتى من
عدد المشاركين خامسا واخيرا هناك قريه
افتراضيه فيلم
مسؤولين عبر الافاتارز وهناك جناح لشركه
ارامكو طارت فيه مشاريعه من الطاقه
المتجدده الهدف من هذه القريه ايجاد حلول
لبعض مشاكل البيئه
سمعت الطيران السيئه في نيبال لا تنبثق من
عدم فسجل هذه الدوله الواقعه بجبال
هيمالايا حافل بالكوارث الجويه نبات
معروفا ان ظروف الطيران الصعبه بالبلاد
تقف خلف هذه الحوادث مثل طقس العاصف
وانخفاض الرؤيا والتضاريس الجبليه فنبال
التي يبلغ عدد سكانها 99 مليون نسمه تحوي
ثمانيه من اعلى 14 جبلا في العالم
الطائرات الصغيره مشاهدينا كذلك التي
تستخدم للوصول الى الاجزاء النائيه
والجبليه في البلاد تساهم بسمعه الطيران
السيئه هذه الطائرات تحتوي على 19 مقعدا
او اقل وتكثر فرص تحطمها من خلال الاحوال
الجويه السيئه بحسب تقرير هيئه الطيران
المدنيه التعليم كما اكد طبعا مشغله
الطائرات ان بلادهم تفتقر الى المنشات
التي تتيح توقع الاحوال الجويه الدقيقه
خصوصا في المناطق الجبليه النائيه فالطقس
سريع التغير في الجبال في هذه المناطق
مطارات النيبال مشاهدينا الجزء الاكبر من
المشكله مطار لوكلا مفعلان الواقع شمال
شرقي البلاد يعد اخطر مطار في العالم مع
تمركز مدرج المطار على منحدر بين الجبال
كما نشاهد هنا يذكر ان القطاع الطيران في
النيبال شهد الزهارا بسبب السياحه غير انه
واجه مشكله في ضمان سلامه الرحلات بسبب
عدم كفاءه الطيارين والنقص في الصيام
[موسيقى]
بعدما رفعت الصين القيود التي لا طالما
فرضتها بخصوص كورونا تزداد المخاوف من
تفشي خطير لفيرس كورونا في البلاد مع بدء
حركه تنقلات السكان الثانويه الواسعه التي
تتضمن مع الاحتفالات بنسبه السنه الجديده
حفظ فيلم افاتار على صداره شباك التذاكر
في الولايات المتحده للاسبوع الخامس على
توالي محققا ايرادات تجاوزات 38 مليون
دولار خلال عطله نهايه الاسبوع وبذلك
يرتفع اجمالي الايرادات المحليه للفيلم
المنتج من ديزني
والى 570 مليون دولار اضافه الى ارادات
على مستوى العالمي بلغت ما يقارب مليار
ونصف الملياردو دولار
رفضت مشاهدينا قناه العربيه الموجه
الثالثه لتساقط الثلوج على جبل اللوز شمال
غرب السعوديه والذي يتبع لمنطقه نيوم جبل
اللوز يرتفع لمسافه اكثر من 2500 متر مربع
فوق مستوى سطح البحر
اليوم في درجه حراره تصل الى صفر مئويه
هي الموجه الثالثه التي تشهدها القمه خلال
هذا العام
مشاهدينا ختام التاسعه مع العناوين
روسيا تهدد بحرق دبابات الغرب وتحذيرات
غربيه لاوكرانيا من التقليدي من اهميه
بخمس استراتيجيه
امام البرلمان الاوروبي تطالب بالتشدد مع
ايران وادراج الحرس الثوري على لائحه
الارهاب
على
الموضهار طبيبات فقدنا العمل تحكيان
[موسيقى]
الريشان
مافيا صقليه وخزان اسرارها في قبضه الشرطه
وايطاليا تصف اعتقاله بالنصر الكبير